so cowboy the reds take on jake arrieta
three in the third
seven runs seven hits three homers i
think we can already see here early that
he's got way more movement than what he
had at any point in time
in the ball game in cincinnati
suarez skies it to deep but playable
left center
he at half on a sun splash day
it'll bring up jesse winker the left
fielder cubs do shift against winker
patrick wisdom by himself on the left
side here comes the 1-1 by arietta
winker swings and lines one into right
field for a base hit
it's cut off by ortega who quickly gets
it into the infield
to keep winker to a single he's been on
fire this year hitting at 349 coming in
breaking ball after breaking ball after
breaking ball sooner or later number one
either they're going to get used to it
or you're gonna hang it and now another
hot red hitter steps up
into the box nick castellano sitting at
3
58 on the season [ __ ] he has been
determined
he has been highly successful a 15-game
hit streak the best active
in all of the majors and that one over
short into left field base hit
a 16-game hitting streak for nick
castellanos
when you know that the hitter's weakness
is down and away with the breaking ball
so does castiano's he knows that's
you're going to available winker
and the reds strike first a one to
nothing lead over the cubs
on the sacrifice fly by taylor naquin
farmer at first
stevenson at second castellanos at third
two away here in the top half of the
first inning the reds on top of the cubs
one to nothing and it'll bring up the
catcher
first pitch hits barnhart and the reds
will get
another run as coming into score is
castellanos it is two to nothing
cincinnati here in the first inning
in this pitch bounces three feet in
front of home plate
right in front of barnhart he can't get
out of the way this ball bounces
into him jonathan india first pitch
chips it on the ground to third in
between bare hand playing first
not in time india flies through
stevenson scores
it's a three nothing reds lead and the
base is still loaded
well if you're patrick wisdom you pretty
much did everything that you could
possibly
do to make the play but the speed of
india that's the whole difference
in this play on tuesday in our nation's
capital he went five and a third
three hits no runs the reds beat max
scherzer in that game who said afterward
a quote i got outpitched that's just the
way it went
that's where even though i had good
stuff tonight did a lot of things right
tyler malley came in and through better
than me
you've got to tip your hat to him baez
has not only homered once but tripled
twice against mali in his career
goes down on strikes high heat swinging
to miss
cubs go down in order in the bottom half
of the first inning after one cincinnati
three the cubs nothing
nick castianos will step into the box he
singled and scored a run
in the first castiano set the plate the
pitch
he lines one for a base hit in a center
field
big turn at second by winker but he'll
stay right there as half
quickly gets the ball back into the
infield and just like the first inning
the combination of winker and
castellanos
proving dangerous naquin drove in a run
with a sacrifice fly in the first
the 1-0 ground ball the second charging
soul guard and he throws to first
side retired so the reds strand runners
at the corners
at the end of an inning and a half it is
cincinnati three and the cubs nothing
comes down three to nothing as we get
set for the bottom half
of the third inning and a great play by
farmer extends the body makes the throw
and the splits nearly from stevenson
the long stretch well that is a big
time play by kyle farmer that's not an
easy catch
even if you're standing in front of the
ball because of the top spin
and the fact that the ball took such a
funky hop
and he makes it backhand style and the
perfect throw in time
now working quickly and here he comes a
little swung on a little ground ball of
the third baseman
moving to his left is suarez the flip
over to stevenson
out to that turn base 5-3 the put out
suarez the leadoff man for the reds oh
for two
fly out to center field and ground it
out to soul guard
suarez swings hits one high deep left
field way
back and gone over the bleachers
he crushed it way out of here to left
field
suarez with his 12th home run of the
year
reds now lead four nothing change up
up and out over and it went up and out
over
suarez gets all of this one he hits this
ball a long way
just to the left field side of the video
board and
i thought this one was going to end up
on the street so naked at the plate with
a man on first base cubs are shifting
three infielders to the right of second
that one is well hit over by us into
center field stevenson given the wave
half from center throws towards second
it could see the score
a single and an rbi for tyler naquin
as stevenson crosses and the reds expand
the lead
it's five to nothing well that pitch did
not go
where arietta or contreras wanted it he
wanted it off the plate away
that's going to be all for jake arietta
javier baez struck out his first time up
maui looking for his fourth straight one
two three inning to open this ball game
2-2 pitch strike three called got him
looking
fastball grabbed the outside corner
started away and came back
malley is perfect through four he has
punched out five
four perfect innings for tyler malley
3-0
there's a four pitch walk that's the
first base runner against mali who had
been perfect through four
the crowd here at wrigley begins to stir
a little bit as wilson contreras will
come to the plate
cubs down five hap it first contreras
swings and hits that one to dead center
tyler naked will have to play it on a
bounce
first and second nobody away
the cubs have something brewing in the
bottom of the fifth here
at wrigley first base hit for the cubs
and the fans
have been hanging out here on a gorgeous
day at wrigley
waiting now he goes to work here against
eric sogar to strike out victim his
first time up
first and second and that one is taken
for called strike three
sogard angrily throws the helmet away
ali
strikes out three straight after the
walk and singles started the inning
you're one swing away from being right
back in this game and here's the guy who
could do it chris bryant
fly ball shallow right racing in
castillanos
that one is going to be in there for a
base hit a run is in
peterson goes to third brian with an rbi
single cuts you on the board it's 5-1
javier baez
stepping into the box against t.j antone
hard-throwing right-hander payoff
grounded right side india
beats baez to the bag end of ending
antone strands his two inherited runners
two gone in the ninth and it's rafael
ortega
2-1 grounded over antone behind second
farmer
ball game ritz they take down the cubs
in the finale a 5-1
finish